bababooey just gave me the new copy of
movie line magazine and he said just
look through it he goes it's all young
actresses Angelina Jolie is featured so
he is Ababu he goes my girl is Claire
Danes both Claire Danes is mine I got
Madonna but God is mine bababooey he
keeps that under lock and key
why don't you because I had it and and
Carrie why don't I have that who gets
you to keep that under lock and key
I'm embarrassed boy that is thoroughly
ridiculous it's been in Fred's plethora
of courts behind him and it never moved
I never take it out in my plethora of
good I haven't taken it out it's been
there forever it's not because last time
we we had to get it I think you had to
bring it in on real I took it out well
we took it out I'm just saying that I
don't have it I just thought it was in
this oh I'll go dig it up free Howard
right no problem ah both okay today live
from Daytona Beach in Florida 1:00 p.m.
Eastern 11:00 Pacific we've got Justine
Bateman now I don't care what anybody
says about Greece's got the hots for
Madonna I got the hots for Justine
Satori's we'll move back she's mine my
homeboys the beach people are going to
be there my homeboys between his teeth
and lips I don't care what they say
Dweezil back off if you like Justine
Bateman I know I've asked you this
before if you like Justine Bateman and
Dweezil ex Madonna why does the weasel
have tobacco talks about how he loves
Madonna boat but he's not trying to move
in on your girl cuz I think Teresa was a
VJ on there and he was like dating a lot
of girls is roundabout thing no can we
go back and get some of your old tapes
sure hi this is Howard Stern go get him
for a News blimp
dude I've gotten better you haven't over
the lips through the gums look out ears
does he recover I have no explanation
for anything that's on these tapes now
agree that there is student this can be
well let me hear about your homeboys the
Beastie Boys one second Hornsby what we
have going out
or dream we'll be helping out those
teeth and gums are battling oh man and
the lips lips the teeth of battling
we've got concert Saturday night with
the KBC bank and herb Allen and Cassidy
formerly of the snore ship and Amy man
until Tuesday we'll be there as well
concert Sunday night with crowded house
you may have seen them performing live
this past week here at MTV you just be
here with that mouth Josh thing with
itself this is a mouth Josh thing going
I mean right off the bat he's like Joe
he's like okay today live from Daytona
Beach what happened I know him his teeth
dry out and ants inside look at them
words come out like a Marine going
through an obstacle it seriously that
when you get nervous your teeth dry out
big body of work that you're famous for
TV audition on the beach 11:00 Pacific
we've got Justine Bateman now I don't
care what anybody says about Greece's
got the hots for Madonna I got the hots
for Justin Satori's we'll move back
she's the reason move back the fact
we'll get back to where you once came
from my boss says your mind you know
what you just Justine Bateman out Claire
Danes in KCK Stu I took a test that I
got a zero on it what could I say